Chaque année, des milliers de patients
perdent la vie à cause du cancer du foie ou buccal.
Notre meilleur moyen à disposition pour aider ces patients
est une détection et un diagnostic précoces de ces affections.
Comment ces maladies sont-elles détectées et l'usage de l'IA fait-il sens ?
Quand un patient, malheureusement, semble avoir une de ces affections,
le spécialiste va d'abord requérir
des analyses très onéreuses
avec des technologies d'imagerie médicale
telles l'imagerie par fluorescence, une tomodensitométrie ou un IRM.
Une fois les images à disposition,
un autre spécialiste en fait un diagnostic et parle avec le patient.
Vous le constatez, ce processus exige beaucoup de ressources,
deux médecins spécialistes, de l'imagerie médicale très onéreuse,
et ce n'est pas envisageable dans les pays en développement.
Ni d'ailleurs dans de nombreuses nations industrialisées.
Peut-on résoudre ce problème avec l'intelligence artificielle ?
Actuellement, si nous utilisons les architectures classiques d'IA
pour résoudre ce problème, nous aurions besoin de 10 000 --
j'insiste -- de générer 10 000 de ces images médicales si chères.
Ensuite, nous les confierions à un spécialiste
qui les analyserait à notre attention.
A partir ces deux informations,
je peux former un réseau de neurones, ou réseau d'apprentissage profond,
à réaliser des diagnostics de patients.
D'autres approches similaires,
des approches traditionnelles de l'IA, sont pénalisées par le même problème :
un volume important de données, des médecins spécialistes
et des experts en imagerie médicale.
Pourrions-nous concevoir des architectures d'IA
plus évolutives, plus efficaces et plus utiles,
pour résoudre ces problèmes cruciaux auxquels nous sommes confrontés ?
C'est précisément ce que nous faisons au Media Lab du MIT.
Nous avons inventé une série d'architectures d'IA inhabituelles
pour résoudre les défis les plus importants
dans l'imagerie médicale et les tests cliniques.
Dans l'exemple que je vous ai montré, nous avions deux objectifs.
Le premier consiste à réduire le nombre d'images
nécessaire pour former les algorithmes de l'IA.
Notre deuxième objectif, plus ambitieux,
est de vouloir réduire l'usage de technologies d'imagerie médicale chères
pour examiner les patients.
Comment avons-nous fait ?
Pour le premier objectif,
au lieu de commencer avec des dizaines de milliers
d'images médicales chères, comme pour une IA traditionnelle,
on a commencé avec une seule image.
À partir de cette image, avec mon équipe, on a trouvé une manière très ingénieuse
d'extraire des milliards de paquets de données.
Ces paquets d'informations incluent des couleurs, des pixels, la géométrie,
et le rendu de la maladie sur l'image médicale.
En fait, on a converti une image en milliards de données de formation,
réduisant ainsi massivement le volume de données nécessaire à cette formation.
Pour notre 2e objectif, réduire l'usage de technologies d'imagerie médicale
pour examiner les patients,
on a commencé avec une photo normale, à la lumière du jour,
prise avec un appareil photographique reflex mono-objectif, ou un smartphone.
Souvenez-vous maintenant des milliards de paquets d'informations.
On les a superposés à partir de l'image médicale,
créant ce qu'on appelle une image composite.
À notre grande surprise, nous n'avons eu besoin de seulement 50,
j'insiste, seulement 50,
de ces images composites pour entraîner notre algorithme
et le rendre très efficient.
Pour résumer notre approche,
au lieu d'utiliser 10 000 images médicales très chères,
nous pouvons former les algorithmes de l'IA avec des moyens non traditionnels
et utiliser seulement 50 photos de haute résolution certes, mais standard,
prises avec des appareils photos et des smartphones,
et réaliser un diagnostic.
Plus important,
nos algorithmes travaillent déjà aujourd'hui
avec de simples photos des patients prises à la lumière du jour
en lieu et place des technologies onéreuses d'imagerie médicale.
Je suis convaincu que nous sommes sur le point d'entrer dans une ère
où l'intelligence artificielle va avoir un impact incroyable sur notre avenir.
Et je pense au sujet de l'IA traditionnelle,
riche en données mais avec peu d'application,
que nous devrions persévérer dans le développement
d'architectures d'IA non orthodoxes
capables d'accepter des petits volumes de données
et résoudre nos problèmes les plus importants,
principalement dans la santé.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)